Apple not sharing its data I don't think necessarily hurts Apple...
...because that's the secret sauce they want to keep at the end of the day.
You don't see Google sharing its data either.
I think everybody in the room needs to remember, as an individual or a company,...
...there's nothing for free.
So, if you're getting a free service for sharing your data,...
...that's because the data is more valuable than what you pay for it.
The value of data goes up every day that AI advances.
At some point, there will be a market for it.
I think Apple does the right thing to keep a bunch of it private.
Data's gonna have more value in the future and we're gonna build economies on our data.
Data will become a currency.
Data's the new oil.